[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the top 15
most powerful wizarding artifacts to
have ever existed and will be going
through each one by order of least to
most powerful
you'll notice that common magical
objects like portkeys and ones well most
ones are absent from the list below
that's because this list focuses on the
most powerful artifacts that is to say
rare and historically significant items
that wield great power
rather than those which are common and
owned by many let's get started
number 15 the deluminator starting us
off at number 15 is the least powerful
magical object on our list the
illuminator
also referred to as the put outer the
deluminator is the size and shape of a
cigarette lighter and silver in color
with a moniker like put outer it's not
terribly hard to imagine what this
object is able to do
it puts out nearby lights the
deluminator achieves this by collecting
any form of illumination in close
proximity the operator can then also
return the orbs back to where they came
from simply by opening the device back
up
the first known owner of such an object
was albus dumbledore who bequeathed his
illuminator to ron weasley upon his
death however i will say this the
deluminator appears to have some sort of
a role in the new film which i've yet to
see
so perhaps it's more powerful than i'm
giving it credit for no spoilers please
14. the goblet of fire next up on our
list is the goblet of fire despite its
varied description the fact remains that
this is one powerful goblet it has the
ability to select which students from
participating schools should represent
their institution in the triwizard
tournament
students submit their names for
consideration and those who are chosen
by the goblet are then entered into a
contract that magically binds them to
partake in the tournament
13. the sorting cat the patchwork hat
that once belonged to codrick gryffindor
ranks number 13 on our list why because
it holds all four of hogwarts founding
members intellect within its brimmed
edges the hat was made sentient enough
to sort every student who walks into the
great hall at hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry it's able to
peer inside the mind of young students
decide which of the four houses they
will excel in it beats out the goblet of
fire because it has the ability to speak
and form opinions where the goblet does
not 12. the mirror of erised coming in
at number 12 is the mirror of erised
which backwards spells desire
this magical artifact is able to look
inside the mind of any witch or wizard
who stands in front of it identify what
they most desire and show their desires
back to them in their reflection
engraved along the edge of the mirror
are the words i show not your face but
your heart's desire backwards
it is said to be a dangerous and
powerful object as witches and wizards
have stood before it mesmerized by what
they saw and simply withered away
11. the pensive
at number 11 we have pensives rare and
powerful artifacts you likely remember
that dumbledore possessed one which sat
in the headmaster's office throughout
most of the harry potter series pensives
were typically round basins made of
either stone or metal into which ancient
symbols and runes had been carved they
are the receptacles of an owner's
memories which take the shape of silvery
wisps
any witch or wizard can immerse
themselves into a pensive and experience
the owner's recollections firsthand
before we get to number 10 i just want
to mention that only 22 percent of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content and want more then please
subscribe to support the channel 10.
prophecy orbs
just as pensives can show a witch or
wizard the past prophecy orbs can hold
prediction records about the future true
prophecies are hard to come by which is
likely the reason that these valuable
predictions were kept protected in orbs
in the department of mysteries of the
ministry of magic that is until most of
them were destroyed in the battle of the
department of mysteries in 1996
while similar nature to a pensive
prophecy orbs rank higher on my list
because they are able to tell you
something this has not happened yet
rather than something that has
nine time turners and while we're on the
topic of time that brings us to number
nine time turners we first see one of
these in the prison of azkaban when
hermione granger uses one to enable her
to take a larger than average class load
ultimately her and harry use the time
turner which looks like a small rotating
hourglass to go back in time to save
lives very powerful stuff
of course traveling back in time comes
with many rules and dangers which is why
the ministry of magic prohibits their
use without express permission eight
ravenclaw's diadem coming in at number
eight is the first magical artifact that
could alter the abilities of the wearer
it is said that this beloved diadem of
hogwarts founder rowena ravenclaw had
the power to instill wisdom to whoever
wore it upon their head
unfortunately after years of belonging
to rowena the relic had a somewhat
tragic outcome stolen by rowena's
jealous daughter helena and then turned
into a horcrux by lord voldemort it was
ultimately destroyed by fiend fire seven
the sword of gryffindor the second and
last of the founders relics to be
included on our list today is the sword
of gryffindor
while it doesn't have the ability to
give whoever wields it greater power it
is an incredibly powerful weapon in
itself
which magically presents itself to any
worthy gryffindor who is in need
six the cloak of invisibility number six
on today's list is one of the three
deathly hallows
the invisibility cloak
certainly the most low-key of the three
hallows its power and magic are
undeniable
as is made clear by its name this is an
ancient cloak that renders the wearer
invisible to those around them according
to legend it was bestowed upon ignotus
peverell by death himself which allowed
him to escape at death's clutches
the cloak was then passed down to the
generations until it was at last given
to harry potter 5. alistair moody's eye
you may be wondering why the magical eye
that alistair madai moody wore ranks so
high on this list well it is the only
object that i'm aware of that can see
through the cloak of invisibility which
in my opinion makes it more powerful
than the cloak itself
while fans have never been given an
official explanation of moody's eye some
believe it must have been taken from
some magical preacher
my theory is that dumbledore enchanted
it with the elder wand which would make
it quite the powerful object indeed
4. the philosopher's stone the magical
item of interest in you guessed it harry
potter and the philosopher's stone this
artifact is my choice for number four
described as a ruby redstone that is an
alchemical substance this object is the
source of the elixir of life which can
make any witch or wizard who drinks it
immortal
the elixir also has the ability to turn
any metal into gold
the only known stone of this kind in
wizarding history was created by nikola
flamel a celebrated alchemist and friend
of albus dumbledore 3 the resurrection
stone number three on today's list is
yet another stone but one that does
somewhat the opposite of the
philosopher's stone the resurrection
stone has the ability to bring a witch
or wizard's loved ones back from the
dead
or at least a form of them it is another
one of the deathly hallows and therefore
was also created by death and given to
one of the three fabled brothers
cadmus peverell
later in its story the stone was set
into marvolo gaunt's ring which
voldemort stole not knowingly stone was
concealed inside and turned into a
horcrux dumbledore destroyed the ring
sometime later however the resurrection
stone remained intact a testament to its
incredible power
2. the veil one of if not the oldest
magical artifact in the wizarding world
that also possesses great power is the
veil an ancient stone archway with a
black ragged curtain hanging from the
top the veil is a physical manifestation
of the gateway between the land of the
living and the land of the dead
those on the side of the dead cannot
come back to the living however they can
murmur to those on the other side if
they sense a loved one nearby on the
other hand a witcher wizard can pass
through from the mortal world to the
land of the dead but once they do so
they cannot return number one the elder
wand topping our list today at number
one is the elder wand the third and
final of the deathly hallows created by
death and the most powerful wand wizard
kind has ever known the elder wand made
its owner invincible in a jewel that is
however it also brought death and
destruction to almost all who possessed
it including the original owner antioch
peverell who was murdered by another
wizard seeking its power
making it the most formidable and deadly
artifact to have ever existed as
xenophilius lovegood put it the bloody
trail of the elder wand is splattered
across the pages of wizarding history
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what do you think of
today's list did i miss any magical
artifacts that you think should have
made it do you agree that the elder wand
is the most powerful object to have ever
existed let me know your thoughts in the
comments below what's your list and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel
until next time remember perhaps those
who are best suited to power are those
who have never sought it
you